[Music]
Assi is always under the threat of demons. The one who
fights on the church line
is the exorcist. I'm really looking forward to the school festival. I like how
simple my brother is. He's hiding something. I'm fascinated by the color. I
don't have time to ignore him. My youth is short.  For the
first time, I felt like it was a bad thing to enjoy myself.From now on, I'm a
classmate of all of you, so please take care of yourself.I learned to look at the other side of people's faces a little bit, and then I realized the
contents of the main meeting, where evil hands are about to sneak up on Asia.  What was the point of paying all the money for pollution?
I don't trust anyone.
Find Izumo. Why do you answer that? Answer me. It's
starting to get interesting to me. He
declared war on your group of soldiers.  I'm here to say I
don't need a half-baked rhythm, Illuminati.What is the
purpose of the Illuminati?Wouldn't it be better if we were strong too?What's
most important to me, we'll definitely take it back.Blue
Exorcist Shimane Illuminati
Edition